la cigale c'est assez nul quand même
franchement chanté tout l'été puis
tandis que la fourmi tanfin top fourmis
mais bon moi je voulais vous parler
d'eux un problème que j'ai eu une
dispute scientifique avec un chercheur
étranger qui s'est mis à écrire que il y
avait des systèmes d'anticipation
partout dans la nature chez les plantes
chez les animaux et puis un moment donné
ça m'a un peu agacé je me suis dit 'mais
mais quand même on peut être les
feuilles tombent en automne pourquoi pas
mais quid de la modélisation de la
puissance de calcul l'évaluation de
toutes les performances intellectuelles
qu'on peut associer à nos à nos
décisions et donc j'avais l'impression
quand même que on parlait pas de la même
chose mais bon comme le temps passe on
s'est reposé quelques fois je me dis bon
je vais prendre mon bâton pèlerins
intérieure et je vais retrousser les
manches et essayer d'approfondir le
sujet et c'est ainsi que je me suis
intéressé aux capacités d'anticipation
des animaux a besoin de comprendre a
besoin de creuser le sujet alors je me
suis intéressé aux animaux comme un
étranger enfin comme un anthropologue
j'ai étudié les éthologues ceux qui se
tuent qui étudie les animaux pour voir
comment il s'y prenait ce qu'ils
disaient qu'est ce que je pouvais
apprendre de tout ça voilà
et alors c'est très intéressant parce
qu'on voit dans l'histoire de
l'éthologie on a parti de l'hypothèse
que nous on est très intelligent et les
animaux pas du tout et puis
progressivement au fil du temps on
apprend à les connaître mieux et on
découvre qu'ils sont un peu moins bête
que ce qu'on pensait et on le redécouvre
des capacités sur certains points comme
la mémoire
le langage l'apprentissage la
socialisation etc
et puis bon le long du chemin on
découvre même que enfants ils ont
certaines aptitudes
on n'a pas qu'ils sont étonnantes
l'écholocation la thermo sensibilité ou
l'électrosensibilité du requin qui crée
pas d dirait des différences
fondamentales mais probablement qui
créent des intelligences spécifique
c'est-à-dire que leur cas n'est pas
moins intelligents que nous parce qu'ils
l'électrosensibilité différemment alors
je mentionnerai de trois exemples qui
nourrissent un peu cette idée
par exemple la gouvernance on a parlé
tout à l'heure des vols d'oiseaux bien
les pigeons apparemment sont capables de
faire la différence en termes de
gouvernance sociale entre celui qui sait
bien les piloter dans les airs le pilote
qui oriente tout le monde et puis le
mâle dominant qui saura expliquer que
faire à au groupe
quand on est arrêté et donc c'est pas
les mêmes pilotes lorsque on voit bien
qu'il faut pas que le fossé music
cuisinier français par allemand fera les
bons donc on sait faire ça y est aussi
la coopération
par exemple les orques savent très bien
avec en étant plusieurs rabattre des
bancs de poissons et avec leur queue
faire d'énormes choc qui a barh sourdis
les poissons et ensuite les ont plus qu
à faire la collecte et à tour de rôle
joue l'un ou l'autre rôle est donc tout
le monde est content notre forme de
coopération typique qui montre quand
même que on est face à des système très
sophistiqué
les requins se font nettoyer les dents
des tarterêts par les tout petits
poissons qui se garde bien de manger et
qui sont quelque sorte leur dentiste et
qui permettent aux requins d
d'avoir un retour enfin une évolution de
rangées de dents et après l'autre dans
des temps raisonnables donc une
coopération et aussi des formes
d'intelligence alors je mens ce montre
juste là le le tableau de quand un des
deux tableaux de kenzy candice et un
singe bonobo qui voyait il ya un tableau
de sa une à un autre ça fait à peu près
500 symbole qu'il a mémorisé totalement
et qu'il est capable d' agiter
d'actionner pour dire quelque chose
voire composé des mots avant une syntaxe
bien plus rapidement que aucune personne
qui a été capable de l'aider à créer
cela enfin qui a créé sa et qui s'occupe
de lui donc là on a une forme de
mémorisation totalement étonnante
voilà et puisqu'on est dans
l'anticipation parce que ça qui
m'intéresse
eh bien voyez le pélican là au fond
l'anticipation c'est un décalage
temporel qu'on essaie de rendre
favorable et évidemment avant de prendre
la décision de plongée il va plomb il
sait qu'il va plonger non pas là où le
poisson et au moment où il prend cette
décision mais là où ils estiment qu'il
va être et le résultat est là
c'est une anticipation assez
rudimentaire mais enfin je souhaitais
pour vous expliquer de ce qui
m'intéresse alors justement dans le
domaine de l'anticipation
on a toutes sortes de phénomènes très
intéressant certains font appel à
beaucoup d'instinct et un petit peu
moins d'intelligence peut être encore
qu'il faut étudier ça plus à fond et l
inverse alors par exemple l'hibernation
l'hibernation c'est une anticipation les
migrations les migrations saisonnières
des animaux aussi mais après on trouve
d'autres systèmes plus sophistiqués
comme l' alerte avec des spécialisations
capable d'identifier et de signaler les
types de dangers et pas seulement le
fait qu'il ya danger et que faire par
rapport au type de danger dans quel sens
aller mentionnons aussi les systèmes de
construction très élaborée par exemple
les toiles d'araignée qui sont vraiment
des systèmes qui s'adaptent à toutes
sortes de contexte ou bien les terriers
des castors qui prévoit de multiples
chemins de fuite est juste en passant je
vous signale que healy a en ce moment
des études fantastique sur les espèces
qui ont des terriers avec des portes de
sortie autre que le point d'entrée et
celles qui ne sont pas capables de le
faire
donc ça c'est très intéressant il y a
naturellement aussi les techniques de
chasse j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure
et puis on a toutes sortes de deux
systèmes liés à la résolution des
problèmes
alors il des problèmes simples par
exemple le corbeau qui veut boire dans
un verre mais l'eau est bien trop basse
pour son bec
alors il va prendre des cailloux faire
élever le niveau de l'eau jusqu'à ce
qu'ils puissent boire c'est un problème
tout simple et des problèmes plus
compliqué comme par exemple franchir une
rivière alors quand une fourmi ce qu'ont
fait ou bien à faire face à une pression
migratoire ou fait par une pression
climatique ou bien faire face aussi à
des adaptations qui ne sont imposés par
l'homme
ça c'est des problèmes plus complexes ou
c'est pas juste une question niveau
d'eau de trou de c
et on voit que les animaux se débrouille
pas trop mal vieilli l'on limite cette
limite c'est celle là c'est celle où
l'homme bouffon instaure une destruction
des habitats tels que on arrive plus on
n'arrive plus à résoudre les problèmes
on est au delà
mais l'homme non plus n'arrive plus donc
on est on est un peu égalité alors
j'aime en évaluer juste ça d'un côté on
a le l'homme et son intelligence qui est
capable de performances étonnantes dans
la productivité aussi dans la complexité
des ou en tout cas la complication des
problèmes disent qu'il aborde et l'autre
côté on a des animaux qui y ont comme
force d'intelligence l'adéquation
systémique une bonne adaptation à un
écosystème une proposition mans et puis
le respect des équilibres par rapport
aux autres
et puis bon on voit quand même que
certains sont là depuis 100 200 millions
d'années ce qui est quand même pas mal
par rapport à nous on a encore du chemin
à faire pour y arriver
et si on regarde un peu les bombes à
retardement dont qui ont été évoqués
déjà aujourd'hui certaines d'entre elles
explosion démographique la pollution le
réchauffement climatique
les problèmes de santé obésité le sel le
sucre les antibiotiques qui veulent
bientôt plus un clou et c'est donc on a
on a vraiment toute une série de bombes
à retardement et on peut se poser la
question je la pose de manière
provocante si l'intelligence humaine et
pas une sorte de dérèglement est en tout
cas qu'il entend voit pas le rattrapage
on trouve des solutions qui génère
d'autres problèmes et qui semble être au
delà notre après quelques générations
problèmes et de coûts à l'avance au delà
de nos capacités de réflexion et même si
on s'y met à plusieurs en tout cas en
l'état actuel donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
bon se met à réfléchir à la nature aux
animaux aux sources qu'on appelle bio
inspirée au biomimétisme on se dit
peut-être là il ya il ya des idées à
creuser
effectivement certaines sont très
intéressante
comment le gecko fait pour se tenir au
plafond comment la tique n'est pas elle
même atteinte par les les problèmes
d'auteuil d'immunisation de dante
immunisation comment faire pour faire un
fils aussi résistant que le fils de
l'araignée ça c'est très intense mais
personnellement puisque je m'intéresse à
ces questions là je dirais que je
m'intéresse quand même au problème
d'anticipation bio inspirée un peu plus
complexe alors bien sûr certaines je ne
peux pas suivre par exemple le sens du
sacrifice ou bien les préférences à
l'accouplement c'est plus difficile à
interpréter bien sûr mais d'autres s'en
sont pris très pratique
par exemple les différentes formes de
coopération dont certaines amène des
complémentarités inédite
j'en ai mentionné une tout à l'heure
avec le requin et le dentiste le poisson
dentiste mais il ya bien d'autres
voilà le système des changes qui amènent
des régulations et non des dérégulations
et puis il ya les formes d'intelligence
collective merci d'avoir préparé le
terrain puisque il ya effectivement
énormément de type 2 forme
d'intelligence collective chez les
animaux certaines font appel à des
capacités ferro monique pour trouver des
chemins préférentiel d'autres permet de
gérer des situations de pression
climatique d'autres encore des formes
d'adaptation à la pression créée par
l'homme
donc il y a effectivement différentes
formes des formes de coopération
différentes formes deschamps différentes
formes d'intelligence collectif et le
mot important ici ces différentes
au fond le en lisant ou en sommes en
écoutant ce que je dis lie à une musique
profonde qui valorise la diversité alors
la diversité est bien ça veut dire tout
simplement que la fourmi sans la cigale
elle va pas loin je vous remercie